no les parece una ironía que el menú
infantil se compone de todos estos
alimentos como pizza hamburguesa papitas
nuggets todo lo que en esa foto
alimentos que nosotros como adultos
siempre evitamos porque estamos a dieta
o el doctor no lo quita porque estamos
enfermos de una cosa o la otra
entonces en otras palabras estamos
creando un amor hacia esos alimentos
desde pequeñitos para que el niño crezca
adolescente le digamos no no puedes
comer eso resultas gordo por eso estás
cansado por eso no pones atención o será
que nosotros de adultos nunca llegamos a
hacer esta conexión entre comida y
comportamiento
en los últimos 40 años el número de
niños obesos en el mundo se ha
multiplicado por 10 los porcentajes de
déficit de atención y diabetes tipo 2
está creciendo descomunalmente en el
mundo entero seríamos la primera
generación que va a vivir más enferma y
más corta que sus padres
toda la expectativa de vida que fue
alargada por la tecnología
descubrimientos está haciendo está
siendo afectada hoy en día por las
enfermedades crónicas
será que esto tiene algo que ver con
nuestra alimentación
pues sí claro que sí ya es hora que
nosotros sacamos esa conexión entre
alimentación y enfermedad de dolor de
cabeza migrañas insomnio depresiones y
mil otras cosas más enfermedades
crónicas causadas por la alimentación es
más causante es cansado de más muertes
que el cigarrillo el alcohol accidentes
de tránsito y según la organización de
las naciones unidas de la agricultura
alimentación
la obesidad está matando a más personas
que la violencia el crimen y el
narcotráfico en américa latina y el
caribe
entonces sí si lo pensamos claramente
nuestra alimentación tiene muchísimo que
ver con nuestra alegría
nuestra felicidad la de nosotros y la de
toda nuestra familia
y también sé que pueda haber personas
que piensan o hasta me digan hoy ella es
súper aburría debe ser súper aburrida no
come esto sino que es como esta otra
costa verde matas lo que sea pero déjeme
preguntarle si yo les parezca aburrida
oh mi querido me quito dos años les
parece aburrido
si él está lleno de energía y vitalidad
precisamente para desmontar este
pensamiento de que aburrido yo una
amante de la cocina y la comida natural
diariamente por mis redes sociales trata
de mostrar y comer saludable y natural
no es aburrido no es difícil de pruebas
tú y yo que no soy una chef profesional
pero cada día aprendo poniéndole amor
poniéndole creatividad y aprendo en mi
cocina yo solita entonces no es aburrido
no es difícil puede ser súper delicioso
y hasta te puedes comer todas las
cositas que vimos ahorita de la
hamburguesa la pizza todo eso pero hecho
con mejores ingredientes ingredientes de
calidad mínimamente procesados en su
estado más natural mientras con el
corazón porque créanme que siempre hay
una mejor versión para todo mi familia
futuremark es testigo es orgullosamente
hoy puedo decir que no solo tengo como
responsabilidad a mi esposo
a mi hijo ya mis dos perritos sino a
esta comunidad futuro manjar que está
creciendo conmigo un poquito cada día
más con esto que hago con tanto amor y
empeño todos los días
esto es una foto de un grupo de mamás
que se llama power mamás estas son unas
mamás que empezaron la alimentación de
sus niños conmigo me dieron ese
privilegio y ahorita los niños para el
colegio son super saludables no se han
enfermado son los niños muy felices
y la verdad me siento demasiado
orgullosa que es hasta mi comunidad
[Música]
para los que se me quedaron en las
cifras alarmantes del futuro en estas
próximas nominaciones no se preocupen la
solución está en nuestras manos y ya les
voy a mostrar qué tan fácil puede ser
primero les voy a contar un poco más de
mí para contextualizar los quiere siendo
siempre fui muy saludable porque porque
un lado por un lado mi papá nos inculca
la importancia del deporte y por el otro
lado mi mamá se encargaba siempre que no
estás loncheras fueran hechas en casa
nunca había ni papitas ni gaseosa ni en
nuestra lonchera ni en nuestra casa
ahorita pensándolo bien puedo ver que de
pronto en lo que se pudo haber fallado
en el momento fue en olvidarnos un poco
de la palabra dieta del flaco de gordo
de subir de bajar algo muy común en
latinoamérica como por ejemplo poder
comer helado y no sentir culpa
para hacer mi historia corta me adelantó
al momento en que la vida me sorprendió
con un bebé fue ahí donde tuve la
inspiración y se me prendió el bombillo
de lanzarme como una como buena
apasionada y luchadora de mis ideas a
escribir y lanzar de forma independiente
mi libro
fue una locura aprendí muchísimo de eso
estoy viendo los frutos de esa horita
también puedo decir que desde ese
momento fue que yo empecé a crear la
relación que tiene por la comida a mi
favorita
quien ha sido mi sujeto de estudio
[Música]
vale la pena aclarar que el embarazo no
es el momento para dejarnos llevar por
esos famosos antojos no por lo contrario
es cuando mejor tienes que comer porque
de eso va a depender sistema inmune de
tu niño propensa a alergias mil otras
enfermedades empiezan desde la nutrición
prenatal
así fue entonces como tuve este niño
[Música]
tuve la oportunidad de amamantarlo me
encanta jugar gritar
jugar y comer desde muy pequeñito pero
como lo logré
desde que nosotros empezamos la
alimentación complementaria se lo
hicimos como una experiencia empezamos
con frutas con verduras cosas comida
real natural no nada empacado ni
proveniente de un tarrito con mil
ingredientes añadidos como por ejemplo
azúcares adictivas grasas hidrogenadas
destructoras estos ingredientes que
están presentes en productos que
nosotros consumimos a diario de
compañías a las que le confiamos nuestra
salud y alimentación
será que nosotros somos tan ingenuos que
pensamos que nuestro gobierno va a
regular mejor nuestra comida porque
ellos quieren lo mejor para nosotros
la triste realidad es que esto no es así
así que toma cartas en el asunto de tus
ingredientes
escoge mejor tus productos y no trajes
enteros
tocar oler sentir texturas frío caliente
dulce salado todas estas cosas eran lo
que nosotros les mencionábamos a él
experimentar nunca forzando sino
ofreciendo y respetando su habilidad
natural con la que los niños nacen de
comer intuitivamente los niños nacen con
esto pero nosotros de adulto dañamos por
qué por qué le damos cucharada tras
cucharada tras cucharada de comida no
apliquemos el abre la boca el avioncito
que viene la china o hasta que no te
comas todo no te para de la mesa o peor
aún me deja limpio el plato no por lo
contrario como les dije ahorita todo
tiene que venir desde el amor desde el
respeto dejándolo comer hasta cuando
ellos estén satisfechos ellos tienen la
habilidad para hacerlo y no se preocupen
que no se van a morir del hambre
entonces qué pasó con el menú infantil
pues el man infantil no existe lo que
los niños como debería ser muy parecido
a lo que nosotros comemos su plato
debería haberse casi igualito a nuestro
plato pero ahí es donde entramos a
evaluar qué es lo que lleva a tu plato
vamos a hacer un ejercicio
me lo pregunta el vecino a la persona
que tiene en el lado cuál fue la última
verdura o fruta que se comió el día de
hoy
[Música]
y qué
y listo
sabían que según la encuesta de la
situación nutricional en colombia
uno de cada tres colombianos entre los 5
y 64 años no come frutas diariamente y 5
es cada 7 colombianos no consume
verduras
esto nos lleva a una triste cifra del 70
por ciento de la población colombiana
que no consume ni frutas ni verduras
diariamente
sabías también que el 75 por ciento de
lo que aprenden los niños es viéndonos y
solo el 25 es por lo que nosotros le
decimos
ahí es donde vuelvo a decirles los que
es lo que les dije ahorita la solución
está en nuestras manos nosotros somos el
ejemplo y de nosotros va a depender el
futuro de nuestras próximas generaciones
así que vamos a crearles a ellos y
arreglarnos nuestra propia relación con
la comida cómo vamos a hacerlo muy
sencillo
piensa que la comida es esa gasolina y
de su calidad depende que también
funciona esta máquina la comida nunca no
es premio ni es castigo no apliquemos el
si te comes el bróculi te doy helado o
si te portas bien te doy torta y ojo
adultos con el hoy me fue súper bien
esta reunión me merezco una hamburguesa
doble triple papitas gaseosa y helado
o adultos también con utilizar comida
para distraer a los niños o para que
dejen de llorar porque estamos cansados
y se nos va a explotar la cabeza es ahí
cuando esto se nos vuelve un problema
psicológico entonces no nos preguntemos
de ese adulto después que come come
buscando reconfortarse
y si nos vamos por estos alimentos y no
por estos otros es porque eso es tan
ayudará a correr más rápido a ganarle a
tu amigo en ese juego que tanto te gusta
a responder todas las preguntas de la
profesora nunca flaco nunca gordo nunca
dieta sino fuerte rápido ágil feliz
[Música]
vamos a conectarnos ya conectarlos a
ellos con los alimentos de donde sale
esto de dónde viene lo otro vamos a
fincas a granjas sembremos maticas y
ramitas y vamos las juntos que ser vamos
al supermercado a mercados vamos a
cocinar en familia y yo sé que el tiempo
es una de las tres cosas más comunes
porque la gente no cocina en familia
pero vamos a hacerlo ponemos una vez a
la semana no se necesita mucho más te
aconsejo de todo corazón que si tú
tienes ayuda y no estás encargado de la
cocina en tu casa monitorea que van tu
comida coge esa responsabilidad de tu
salud de cerca
ahí estamos creciendo muchas matica
no cree en ustedes
que es muchísimo más probable que un
niño o hasta un adulto que normalmente
no comería cosas por su sabor su textura
su apariencia esté muchísimo más
dispuesto a probar si él hace parte del
proceso para hacerlo como por ejemplo en
esta foto mi bebé jaime le echo el limón
a esa ensalada y esta ensalada tenía
muchas cosas que él normalmente no comía
muchas cosas quedan muchos vegetales
crudos y es simplemente el simple hecho
que él me ayudó a echarle limón hizo que
la probará y se la comiera
no les parece muy interesante
yo la verdad me emocionó muchísimo es
solo pensarlo y no se preocupen que no
tienen que todos ser unos expertos yo no
soy no todos no todos tienen que cocinar
pero si podemos hacerlo un plan de una
vez a la semana estar todos unir a toda
la familia
no todos cocinan pero pueden estar ahí y
pasarle este amor y esa buena energía a
los alimentos qué es lo que hace la
comida tan rica en sabor y en nutrición
para el cuerpo y para el alma la comida
es la mejor forma de mostrar amor
así que pongámonos super creativos con
ellos vamos a hacerle unos pancakes en
arbolito de navidad vamos a jugar con
los brókeres como si fueran un bosque
vamos a darle un descanso a ellos de la
tecnología ellos lo necesitan a gritos
[Música]
tú necesitas conectarte con tu cuerpo y
tu alimentación vamos a darle a nuestro
cuerpo lo que necesita para poder ser
mejor mamá papás hermanos hijos
estudiantes profesores líderes
vamos a darle esa gasolina premiun que
nuestros niños necesitan para jugar
crecer reír estar saludables y
simplemente poder ser niños
te invito a que el cambio lo hagas tú
nosotros como comunidad como colegio
como ciudad como país como mundo se los
aseguro que si nosotros empezamos desde
nuestro círculo más cercano pronto este
efecto dominó llegará a las grandes
industrias forzándolas a mejorar sus
productos y tácticas de mercadeo
esto es una foto de mis clases mensuales
que hago en mi casa en miami porque yo
siento la responsabilidad de impactar el
mundo a mi circulito alrededor porque
porque quiero tener mamás que piensan
como yo y mi hijo pueda tener mas
amiguitos con los que jugar que sus
mamás sean como yo y así vamos agregando
la voz en tu círculo más cercano no
necesitan nada más
para terminar les cuento esta historia
ya hace un par de meses que fui con mi
hijo jaime estamos en un mercadito al
aire libre como siempre corriendo de un
lado al otro pero llegamos a la parte
donde estaban las frutas y los vegetales
acomodados en cajas y él empezó a
nombrarlos todos luego llegamos a la
parte donde estaban las papas había
muchos tipos diferentes de papas como
pueden ver en la foto y a todas en los
nombró papas ya mí me pareció muy
increíble porque inclusive para un
adulto no es tan obvio y además está más
chiquito entonces puede sonar un poco
pero fue desde ese momento que yo me di
cuenta que mi labor como madre que
empezó desde que era un bebé a tratarlo
como una personita
a ofrecerle a aplicar todas estas cosas
que yo les dije había valido la pena y
siento que estoy viendo los frutos de
esa horita y vale la pena aclarar que no
es que el coma tonos vegetales y
ensaladas y cosas raras del mundo pero
la verdad él si se atrae un poquito más
a probar y no sé si él seguirá después
así cuando crezca pero está en mí el
nunca parar de ofrecerle con amor con
respeto con paciencia y mostrarle el
ejemplo conmigo mismo
y si te pregunto ahorita cuál es el
mejor regalo que le puedes dar a tus
hijos
que tú que me respondería el mejor
regalo que les pueden dar
la educación es una muy buena respuesta
pero vamos a agregarle un poquito más el
mejor regalo que le puedes dar a tus
hijos es la educación a una buena
alimentación el mejor regalo que le
pueden dar a sus hijos es el amor por
tener una muy buena salud y cómo vamos a
hacerlo educando desde el corazón
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]